what percentage of trans kids
that are put on
drugs are women versus or little you
know girls versus little boys
yeah it's interesting and it seems to be
changing every day for a while it was
thought that the overwhelming majority
of people who identify as trans are men
uh claiming to be women whether they got
any hormones or surgery or not but we're
seeing an exponential increase in the
number of girls and young women who are
going to gender clinics going on
testosterone getting mastectomies that
are not medically necessary
abigail schreier has documented all of
this in her book irreversible damage i
don't know the stats for the u.s but i
know that in the uk in a matter of just
a tiny handful of years i think it's
three years the percentage of young
girls and women who went to the nhs
gender clinic shot up four thousand
percent
oh that's awful as if being a teenager
isn't confusing enough i don't know yeah
like people experience anxiety when i
was in grade four
for a multitude of reasons i i cut off
all my hair which i didn't want to be a
little boy i just cut off my hair and
then people were referring to me as a
boy because you kind of look the same
when you're a little kid
and i was on all the sports teams and i
refused to wear dresses
and i like
i was kind of a nerd
so
i would be very concerned for any kid
kind of in the same position that's a
tomboy like there are lots of little
girls that are tomboys i'm certainly not
one anymore but like i i was back then
and i'd be concerned for any kid in a
school that's ideologically that has
ideologically possessed teachers
that are more tomboyish because then
it's like oh well do you feel you know
like you're you identify more with other
like little boy or little boys
are you more comfortable being friends
with boys maybe maybe you want to
express yourself that way maybe that's
what you actually truly are
right and having that kind of
conversation with an adult you'd be so
confused as a kid
yeah i mean that's actually already
happening teachers are telling people
kids as young as four and five that if
they like certain stereotypes then that
actually makes them the opposite sex
i've heard of stories of teachers
making gender closets they literally use
the word closet and when a kid comes to
school dressed in whatever the kids
dressed in
teachers will put kids in the closet and
have them change clothes without their
parents knowing
teachers will
start referring to kids using the kids
chosen name without telling the parents
kids teachers will start referring to
kids using the kids preferred pronouns
without informing the parents this is
happening today